central bank digital currency and what
advantages do
does a stable coin offer that that a
digital dollar
say at the fed would not be able to
offer
thank you congressman barr i'm happy to
i think the first difference is that
stable coins are operational and growing
in the market today and they're built on
uh an open internet technology model so
when we think about all of the things
that we've seen built on the open
internet on these open protocols and
networks whether it's ubiquitous
information exchange communications
interaction
around the world that same open internet
model is the foundation for stable coins
and so
i think that's a fundamental difference
a cbdc which is a con concept right now
it's not operational would very likely
be a very closed-loop technology that's
tightly administered and run by the
government uh and would unlikely be
accessible in the same way that these
open networks are accessible and so i
think that's a critical difference but i
i would come back to the most important
which is that
most payment system innovations in the
world have been driven by the private
sector and i think what's taking place
today with digital currency is is no
different
could stablecoin and in your product uh
could it um address some of the concerns
about china's uh advances
in terms of and and the the threat that
china's advances posed to
sanctions enforcement uh and um
protecting the dollars the world's
reserve currency i think so yes i mean
coming back to to this and and i'll try
and make this point concisely
you know the united states and the u.s
dollar is winning the digital currency
space race today
dollar stable coins are doing trillions
of dollars of transactions the
experimental beta of a chinese yawn
which is government controlled in china
has done 10 billion dollars of
transactions so the united states is
winning
this is has the potential to grow at a
at a very significant speed around the
world and benefit the u.s dollar and
benefit american businesses and
households and so i i think that's one
really really critical thing to
understand and i think
the primacy of this infrastructure and
the development of this infrastructure
it is a strategic national security and
national economic priority for the
united states and we need to get going
on it right now
thank you i have many other questions as
well but my time is expired thank you
madam chair thank you very much
the gentleman from california mr vargas
is now recognized for five minutes
thank you very much
madam chair i appreciate very much
you're bringing this to our our
attention
appreciate the ranking member
everyone participating today especially
the witnesses now one of the things
that's been interesting i've heard a lot
of very high and noble motives today i
think i
don't want to misquote people that but
i've heard that the digital asset world
the open internet model it's for all
people in the world it's easier cheaper
open
free market data it's transparent
reduces risk not increases risk it's
less friction in the marketplace
these things are all great but it's
interesting that most of the people that
i know that have invested in
cryptocurrencies not because of that
it's because they think they can get
rich quick
and the appreciation of bitcoin is
something that they want a part of it's
not because of all these other wonderful
things that the internet can do it's not
the reason at all
secondly it's interesting when i ask
them well you know what
cryptocurrency and digital assets and
bitcoin what it actually is
most of them say no
i just know that you know make a lot of
money and i want to invest and i want
part of it i want to be able to invest
and because i know that that's
appreciated now we've seen this before
unfortunately and it led to i think a
financial crisis around the world when
you were investing in derivatives and
other things that people didn't know
what the hell they were investing and
then it became very problematic so i do
see the risk in this now
i i
have to say when this was a a b problem
or a b issue a billion dollar problem
didn't seem as such a big deal but now
that it's become a trillion dollar issue
and i do think it's challenging that
really the supremacy of the dollar
around the world i do think it's it's
potentially a big problem i i do have
concerns i want to follow on
to what mr barr said uh
um
you know
the issue of
the dollar being the reserve currency
this seems it does challenge does
someone want to comment on that
if not i'll pick on somebody i'm happy
to comment congressman i i i want to
respond to a couple things uh
in your comments i i would i would agree
with the fact that there are
you know there are passerbys and then
there are people who are actively
building and who are very very close to
the technical innovation and i think
like investments in technology companies
or in other businesses that we see in
the stock market
you have people who are investing
because they think it's a business or a
product that might go up they may not
understand the details of uh of a given
pharmaceutical company's science but
they they believe that perhaps
it's an area of innovation and they want
to invest in it and so i do i do agree
that there is that uh distinction um but
i think it is it's certainly incumbent
on all the industry participants to
ensure that there's great amount of
disclosure litera you know financial
literacy around around these products
but more importantly coming back to the
comment about the dollar
i i think there is this growth in
digital assets as a new kind of asset
class and i think what's important to
notice is understanding those in
contrast to fiat currencies um many of
the digital assets in fact i think the
overwhelming majority of the digital
assets are commodities that are have
utility that are used to power some kind
of technology network or protocol
more thought of like an oil
or or gas
than uh
you know than a fiat currency so they
exhibit those properties and i don't
think those will ever rival the dollar
i think they'll grow in value because
they're utilized to help facilitate
all kinds of activity on these
web three applications and networks and
i do believe that with innovations like
stable coins and dollar digital
currencies we could actually see a
dramatic amount of growth in the use of
the dollar globally i'm going to
i'm going to reclaim my time just for a
second because um one of the things that
i see is that we do have digital we have
the digital dollar already i mean the
digital dollar can do all the things
that you guys were talking about today
with the exception that it is a fiat
currency that wouldn't be um you know
as easily manipulated by some nefarious
group because it would be controlled by
the fed in the united states of america
i mean i i do have great apprehension
that
you have um
these cryptocurrencies that are used by
drug traffickers that are used by people
trafficking other human beings and
there's no good way to control it um so
i'm all for
digital currency but why not the dollar
why can't the dollar be the digital
currency why can't we once again
dominate not 60 80 but maybe even higher
with a digital dollar that to me makes
much more sense
and it's much more protected and people
won't have the risk but anyway i uh
i yield back my time but
i did find this a very interesting
discussion thank you
thank you very much the gentleman from
texas mr williams is now recognized for
five minutes
thank you madam chair and for those of
you who don't know me i'm a
small business owner and in texas and
still own those businesses i'm a car
dealer and a former professional
baseball player and when i'm trying to
wrap my head around a new topic
like crypto currencies i try to relate
it back to something i understand like
baseball or business
now some of you may know this but modern
day baseball can really be attributed to
babe ruth
he brought in the live ball here of the
time and introduced power to the
baseball diamond and before this teams
would play small ball
that was very conservative where teams
would literally play for one run a game
the entire objective was simply to get
the ball in play so they could try to
steal their way around the base pass and
there was nothing wrong with this old
way of playing but when the white sox
won the world series in 1906 the entire
team had a total of six home runs all
year but babe ruth came along babe ruth
came along and totally changed
everything in 1920 he set the american
league record of home runs with 54.
to put that into perspective how
fantastic this feat was at the time the
previous mark to uh to be set was by
sock seabold in 1902 with just 16. this
introduced an entire generation of new
baseball fans and for the first time
ever the new york yankees over 1 million
fans came to see them in a single season
now with that being said many of you are
becoming the babe ruth in the financial
space services space
you're introducing blockchain technology
to the financial services industry and
working to upend the tradition and the
traditional way of doing business
and while many economists and so-called
experts have been calling on the
downfall of cryptocurrency and
discounting the future of blockchain
technologies all of you
were working tirelessly to create
something new in order to bring this new
technology to the masses
unfortunately it would only take a few
misguided curveballs we'll say
from washington to undo some of the
progress you've all put into this motion
so my first question to you mr brooks
can you talk about some of the negative
consequences that could happen if we
take a heavy-handed approach to
regulating this developing technology
well mr williams as a long-suffering
dodgers fan i share a lot of the things
you're talking about and i think the era
you're talking about
was an era when baseball went from
focusing on not losing
to an era where it focused on winning
and winning and not losing are not the
same thing so i come back to mr vargas's
question a second ago which i think is
the right way to answer your question
mr vargas asked the question of um
people have the potential to lose a lot
of money these things are volatile
they're risky how do we protect them
from those kinds of issues there are two
ways of answering that
one is to prevent as many people as
possible from accessing this amazing
technology for example the way the
current legal regime works is certain
kinds of assets can only be purchased by
accredited investors meaning rich people
so the only people who can get rich on
this are people who are already rich
that'd be one way of protecting people
from losing money is to make sure that
only the richest can access it
another way of addressing it would be to
make it safer the way that we made
equities safer 40 years ago right we
created mutual funds diversification
sector funds and other things that make
it easier for regular americans from
places like my hometown and colorado
to buy equities without having to be
stock experts
strangely in the u.s we've refused to do
that so far so we don't allow crypto
mutual funds we don't allow people to
diversify the way that they do in canada
germany singapore the united arab
emirates and a series of other regulated
economies around the world so i would
argue the way to win
is to bring more people into the system
more safely not to keep them out at
their own peril great
uh second question we often hear that
crypto industry is the wild wild west
where there is no regulation guiding the
industry but as all of you are aware
that simply is not true the sec and the
cftc are the primary federal regulators
and our states also have strict
regulations that all of you must be
abiding by so mr bankman freed can you
discuss the different layers of
regulation that ftx must abide by as an
exchange and also in order to uphold
customers deposits in your digital
wallets
uh yeah thank you for the question
congressman and um you know putting
aside the 190 other regulatory
jurisdictions that we take part in and
the dozens of licenses that we are
acquiring each month in all of those
in the united states there is the sort
of state level money transmitting
license of regime um with you know money
service business and mtls which uh
you know we and many others are part of
for any margined or financed or
derivatives transactions in the united
states there is a cftc regime
um where uh you know there's licensure
required to offer those products um for
any products that might be
security as a digital asset um one would
it's you know there doesn't exist a
current uh very clear pathway for it um
but that would be an sec registered
regime for it um obviously there's been
lots of discussions about additional
registered um regimes for stable coins
and other assets as well
thank you i think my time is up madam
chairman i yield back
thank you very much the gentleman from
illinois mr caston
who is also the vice chair of the
subcommittee on investor protection
entrepreneurship and capital markets is
now recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair and i came up
vastly before i thought i was going to
which means that you'll have to humor me
for my ill-formed thoughts um
the i really appreciate our witnesses
coming here and i and i also feel
terrible for you because we could have
an entire hearing on stablecoin we could
have an entire hearing on blockchain we
could have an entire hearing
on
no cbdc's i suppose and we could
probably have an entire hearing on
whether or not
things that have forced scarcity are
inherent stores of value except that i
think we resolved that 100 years ago but
yet we still sort of need to debate it
periodically
um
all that said i wanted to start just
focusing on stable coins if i could um
and and mr alaire want to want to start
with you and i'm sure you've seen the
presidential working groups report
um you know raising all sorts of issues
with stable coins primarily around are
they do they really look like money
right you know do they have sufficient
reserve assets behind them
are what are the redemption rules is
there transparency around permission
blockchains the custody of reserve
assets you've read the report i'm sure i
see you nodding could go on
um first question is really simple do
you support the recommendations of that
report for stable coins
so
i support a number of things but not not
uniformly i think there are a number of
challenges with the report um i think
the first maybe to discuss is
really this question of
what form of federal charter ought to be
in place around a large-scale dollar
stablecoin issuer i think the report
recommends that it would be an insured
depository institution but i think one
of the really critical things to discuss
there is an fdic insured bank
is fdic insured because the bank
is taking risk with deposits yeah and if
i get an apologist
i want to just narrow sort of
specifically to the issue of if i
deposit something in a bank that is
indexed to a dollar and i perceive as a
customer that this is
i've eliminated the fx risk right but
now i'm left saying is is it actually
there when i wanted another sufficient
certain setting aside how we get it done
broadly speaking are you supportive of
the idea that if this is going to look
and feel and attract investors with the
expectations that this has all the risk
and liquidity profiles of a dollar that
we should make sure that it actually has
those features absolutely so
full reserve disclosures transparency um
i think definitions around what those
reserves are and the liquidity mandate
on it those are all really critical
features that need to come in place
um if it's full reserve is it is it an
fdic insured product or or is it a
statutory set of constraints around what
the reserves are so those are some of
the things that i think have to be
worked through um so and i want to get
to two more questions so i apologize if
i'm being quick but
in the absence of those protections
being in place
it seems to me that somebody who is
currently holding a stable coin
perceives that they are holding a
currency but in reality is holding
something that is subject to a lot of
exogenous risks beyond their control
which feels a lot more like a commodity
so if if we agree that as of right now
it's not really a currency
would you also be supportive of saying
well we should regulate it as a
commodity until such time as we have the
protections in place to give it the
robustness of a currency that the market
is expecting of it so
i don't agree with that um but i think
it raises a couple of key points um so
the first is and i can only really speak
on behalf of circle here um usdc for
example operates under the same stored
value electronic money and electronic
money transmission statutes that govern
square and stripe and paypal and the
balance is there so today there are
consumer protections there are reserve
requirements around holding of those
assets one-for-one redeemability uh any
money laundering uh requirements 30
bonds that need to be posted to protect
consumers segregation of client funds in
and for benefit of customer accounts so
there's a great deal that's there and so
and we have operated under such statutes
really since 2014 we're the first
company to go and get all those licenses
so there is a framework today i think as
these get larger and and are operating
at a global scale uh i think really it's
does there need to be something more
that's more bespoke to this let me if i
could because i'm just nervous watching
the time here let me let me sort of get
to the last question leave it to the
whole panel and if we're out of time
that's we'll do it we'll follow up
separately
the concern i have is that a stable coin
at some level is an etf right and we
could imagine a stable coin indexed to
all sorts of different currencies and
some kind of baskets of currencies that
are behind there and we and we regulate
those in certain ways with expectations
of
who is bearing the risk to mr
prominent's question
the
we have this emerging world of central
bank digital currencies and i'm
satisfied that no central bank wants to
allow counterfeiting they all want to
protect the integrity of their currency
and so they'll put those rules in place
on the other hand different countries
are going to have very different ideas
about what kind of data they would like
to track
when we trade a central bank digital
currency
and so a question for any of you who
feel technically competent to answer
this
if you have a stable coin that includes
some portion of central bank digital
currencies that are tracking things that
we as americans would not like to track
can we design the stable coin
to insulate the contamination of that
system so that somebody who believes
that they are buying something that
looks like a dollar is not actually
being tracked by our adversaries anybody
like to comment on that i'll make one
quick comment which is one of the
benefits of this technology is the these
stable coins all of the code that they
that they provide and how they interact
is all public and open source and so
everything that functions inside of that
is visible to everyone that interacts
with it and so there is the ability to
have i think greater transparency into
how are these things functioning
including a foreign a foreign-issued
coin i'm i'm out of time but i do have
some things
about
thank you if anyone would like to follow
up i'd love to the gentleman from ohio
mr davidson is now recognized for five
minutes uh thank you madam chairwoman
and thanks to the ranking member thanks
to our witnesses and frankly many people
who've worked literally years to get to
this point
to have a hearing the market has been
way ahead of this and frankly it's been
painful to watch
you know in 2017 and since when you see
the ico market
ripe with people committing fraud or
just regulatory arbitrage taking
advantage of the fact that our
regulators haven't paid attention to bad
actors and it's been especially
frustrating to watch some of our
regulators take aim at people that are
working very hard and very aggressively
to be legitimate businesses to come into
compliance with every kind of licensure
and regulatory regime that our that our
country currently offers it's been
woefully inadequate and so it's so
good to get to this point for the
hearing so thank you and thanks to my
colleagues i've been very encouraged by
the amount of preparation many
colleagues have done
to close the gap in any knowledge
they've had and over the past few years
the number of members of congress that
really understand this space
has certainly increased
three years ago we had a hearing
not really a hearing because as a junior
member i can't hold those or pick them
so
in exasperation we just held a meeting
over at the library of congress and some
of the folks in this room were there or
representatives from your companies were
there and we came up with the most
essential thing was to establish a
bright line test
not just for the players in the industry
not just for the investors but also for
the regulators so that if somebody at
the sec for example says this looks like
a security it's not a form of
interpretive art to say does it really
fit this test
we came up with four part tests that
said it's already created it exists
that it is recorded on a distributed
secure and immutable ledger that is not
controlled by a central authority
that permissionless pure to mere
peer-to-peer transactions can be done
without an intermediary
and it does not represent a financial
interest
in any entity
more important than that particular test
is the fact that there is as mr brooks
you highlighted a speed limit so that
there's some clear thing not just as i
say for the investors not just for the
participants in the market but for the
regulators themselves so that we have
continuity if only there were such a
body that could provide this clarity
my hope is that the next time we have a
hearing we will notice some bills and
we'll be able to talk about particular
text uh towards that
so you know mr brooks when you look at
um stable coins which maybe is the
lowest hanging fruit
some of those are established well in
long-standing things like new york
trusts
some of those
aren't traded in anything they're just
u.s dollars stored in a vault for every
token some have us dollars and
components of m2 like us treasuries some
have other things when you were at the
occ you provided some clarity there and
you also dealt importantly with
self-custody you know mr o'leary you
mentioned that
the code is literally online any of us
right now during the hearing could
download code
and could begin to self-custody
a digital asset so as you look at that
how important is it to provide this
clarity mr brooks
well specifically on the issue of
custody and and self-custody this is a
way that crypto tries to make an advance
over the current system so the issue
with custodial assets we've seen and
this committee's looked at many many
times think about the financial
crisis when there was an issue of
foreclosures and it was difficult for
custodians to produce the original note
that proved whoever was entitled to
enforce that transaction and foreclose
on a property because the piece of paper
had gone missing or the custodian had
merged with another custody company or
whatever one of the things crypto's
trying to do is to use technology so
that you can safe keep your own assets
for free versus having to pay somebody
else to custody it that also provides a
layer of financial privacy something
that this committee usually favors but
sometimes strangely doesn't favor so
self-custody is one of the key things
along with self-ownership and
self-determination on this internet of
value that's really critical to the
nature of the network yeah thank you and
as we've digitized information
it's it's frankly you know
amazing that we've finally digitized uh
money in a way that we can move uh not
just a store of value but a means of
exchange um the the use case for digital
assets has partially been that that it's
this stable store of value certainly
stable coins solved that um some have
pointed out that bitcoin for example
doesn't and you know mr bankman freed um
one of the ways that people have
speculated that the volatilities created
in the market isn't by holders of the
asset or hodlers hold on for dear lifers
as has become known in the space but by
the other big group that owns these
assets which are traders
many of them trade on leverage and so
when you look at leverage you made a lot
of news by saying you know we're capping
people at 20 times leverage that's a lot
of leverage she also pointed out that
the average leverage on ftx was around
2x so could you talk about the
importance of leverage uh in volatility
uh thank you for the question uh
congressman uh the first thing that i'll
say is in cryptocurrencies in digital
assets as like essentially every other
financial asset in the world
more volume trades through futures
contracts than through the spot asset
the reason for this is basically it's
more economically efficient
it's much more capital efficient um the
lack of an immediate delivery
requirement on the physical uh creates
uh a much easier ability for people to
hedge exposure uh for people to express
opinions um and and so for all those
reasons uh you know i think that they're
an important part of the digital asset
ecosystem as error of every other
ecosystem um i'll just briefly say it's
important to have robust risk engines
that monitor uh the positions on these
assets we've gone through multiple very
large up and down moves and been able to
manage positions both times thank you
and thanks so
thanks again for the hearing i feel like
i've spoken to steve case in like 1990
so thanks for the uh the vision that you
guys have and uh thanks for the hearing
madam chairwoman welcome the gentleman
from new york mr torres
is now recognized for five minutes
uh thank you madam chair um so i
represent the south bronx which is often
said to be the poorest congressional
district in america and of greatest
concern to me
are the use cases of crypto that would
improve the lives of the people of the
south bronx i represent a heavy
population of immigrants who often pay
predatory fees in order to send
remittances to their loved ones abroad
so what can crypto blockchain web 3
do for that dominican immigrant in the
south bronx who was burdened by
remittance fees that she cannot afford
how much more affordably and quickly can
the crypto economy facilitate
remittances
mr cascarelli if you could take that
question and please be specific
yes uh thank you for the question
um i think this is a really important
element of the technology which again is
that it's open to anybody
you don't need to have a bank account
you don't need to
in fact rely on any intermediary so
somebody who's an immigrant and wants to
send remittance to a family member
another country is able to do that and
um uh there's ways to deal with both
crypto and to do it uh with a stable
coin and all you need to do is download
a wallet and then you can send it to
somebody else anywhere in the world
and so this is a really powerful
tool for democratization of access
especially for those who have difficulty
getting bank accounts there's no minimum
fees there's no minimum balances
there's no check cashing fees
that are part of this technology and you
can do it in some cases for you know
a penny or less and how much quicker
well this is an important point um
blockchain is part of the beauty of them
is that they're operating 24 hours seven
days a week 365 days a year
so it can be sent just about
instantaneously there's no multi-day
lags
that you have right now and um
that change in the speed is just crucial
because usually it's these lags that
really are very costly i'm going to
interject mr brooks i have a question
about the challenge of enforcing laws
in a world of decentralization whether
it be law enforcement relating to
financial crimes or sec disclosure how
exactly do you enforce the law when
there is no central entity against which
to enforce the law how do we grapple
with that challenge
that is a great question mr torres i
really appreciate you asking it so i'd
say a couple things about it first of
all to the extent that some of the
activity we're talking about is parallel
to activity that happens in the
supervised system my question is why
don't we allow it in the supervised
system again you've heard me say it
before this morning but you have on this
panel a big stablecoin issuer who's
applied for a bank charter doesn't look
like they're going to get it easiest way
to supervise that would be let them in
the banking system and have the occ have
authority over them so i'd start with
that
the second point is lots of these
decentralization protocols are designed
to solve the exact problems that create
the need for enforcement in the first
place because most enforcement in the
securities and banking system is about
some combination of human error human
negligence human greed or human bias and
the point of some of these decentralized
systems is to take that out and have an
open source piece of software everybody
can look at and do with those things
algorithmically so as an example i used
to sit on a bank credit committee we
would decide who got credit and who
didn't and i think we had a really good
system for it but we were human beings
we might have been indulging in implicit
bias we might have made mistakes
algorithms don't do that so some of the
need for what you're talking about goes
away in a decentralized system
and i know there are
you know there are critics who have said
that the blockchain
might not be as secure and as unhackable
as advertised but for me the proper
question is not whether the blockchain
is perfectly secure and unhackable the
question
is whether it's better than everything
else like winston churchill famously
said democracy is the worst form of
government with the exception of
everything else
is there a computer network that is more
secure than the blockchain
well i i think the beauty of the
blockchain is not that it's perfectly
secure it's that it's perfectly
transparent so you can see when
somebody's screwed around but i want to
specifically address security is there a
computer network to your knowledge that
is more secure than the blockchain
i don't know of one but we have a phd in
physics sitting right next to me so
we'll let them
uh if you're talking about any major
globally used blockchain i don't know of
one there are small blockchains that are
less secure all the major ones are
incredibly secure
and one of my concerns about crypto
is that it would present a challenge to
the supremacy
of the us dollars the world's reserve
currency
but what i have found striking is that
the leading stable coin issuers have
actually chosen to peg
their stable coins to
the dollar which strikes me as a vote of
confidence that reinforces rather than
challenges the status of the dollar as
the world's reserve currency so
what are your thoughts on the
relationship between the dollar and the
crypto is it is it as contradictory as
many have feared or could it be actually
complementary
i'll answer that i i actually don't
think that it's um uh contradictory at
all uh what people want is a us dollar
bank account everywhere in the world
people want to be able to have us
dollars and actually that's the hardest
thing to get
and crypto is a
tool for a lot of different things
including bringing communities together
but what people want in order for their
everyday spending it's dollars if you're
in argentina you want dollars if you're
somebody anywhere in the world you want
to have access to dollars and that's the
hardest thing to get access to right now
and that's why tokenize dollars is so
valuable because you don't need to have
a bank account yet you can have access
to the dollar based system and then very
very important tool for inclusion
the gentleman's time has expired the
gentleman from michigan mr heisinger is
now recognized for five minutes uh uh
thank you madam chair and my apologies
to the to the panel i had to leave to
manage a bill on the house floor dealing
with a very exciting issue of libor uh
the i will thank you
you're you're you're welcome uh we're
we're getting there madam chair but
um
to my uh to my colleague from new york i
i do want to point out that this isn't
quite the same but the same idea exists
uh committee republicans released a uh
uh cbdc a central bank digital currency
principles
recently and of those
we had we had said in this
as one of those principles is we need to
we need to make sure that the private
sector leads the way but we need to
ensure that the u.s dollar remains the
preeminent uh
currency and uh so that is a that is a a
common goal uh certainly and and we've
been very aggressive in trying to lay
that out um i've got short amount of
time i'm trying to go through as quickly
as possible
uh and i'm gonna peek around my
colleague from west virginia here uh
trying to get to uh
to mr uh bankman freed real quickly
um and again i apologize i'm not trying
to re-plow ground that has already been
been gone over but how many various
levels and types of regulators do you
currently engage with because i know you
are worldwide you've indicated that you
have multiple regulators that you
currently work with i'm curious if you
can even peg that number
yeah so i mean there are dozens probably
soon hundreds worldwide that we're
engaging with um
and uh and you know that includes all
across europe all across asia um and
then you know within the united states
we're engaging with state money
transmitted money service business
licensure uh we have a cftc license um
for derivatives we're engaging with the
sec um and you know i anticipate more uh
agencies getting involved soon as well
yeah well yes and i want to make sure
that uh that we are not over regulating
that one i'm sure it has cost you an
untold amount of money uh so far and i'm
sure everyone that has been dealing with
that but i also want to make sure no
offense to any of you i want to make
sure that
there are others who are going to be
able to enter that space and that they
are not not being blocked out and that
there is an artificial
a barrier to entry that is going to
allow others to do frankly what you all
did which was be innovative and supply a
product to to people who are looking for
that product
i'm going to have to move really quickly
i'm going to go to mr brooks on a couple
of things
would you describe why establishing
these clear rules of the road is
important
before we uh an important step before we
uh add additional regulation and and
consider that regulation
well mr heisenga it's good to see you
again i think the most important reason
of many is international competitiveness
so other countries make this easier okay
let me just make clear other companies
make this easier other countries i just
came yesterday from the middle east
where in dubai and abu dhabi they have
super clear derivatives regulations
super clear etf regulation they're
trying to lure americans over there to
build these products and they're moving
there so so how are they viewing
these crypto assets differently than
traditional assets i mean
what what if they what if what rubicon
have they crossed that that that we
haven't
and um you know why is it important to
think about digital assets differently
well i i think one of the things that
they figured out is that um crypto
actually is less fundamentally different
than equities in debt than you think it
is it's a risk-on asset that people want
to invest in they want to invest in it
in canada so canada builds a regime for
it they want to do it in germany germany
it's we're the last country standing
that hasn't figured that out it's a
risk-on asset that people want exposure
to as part of asset diversification as
opposed to traditional assets correct
okay
i've got a minute left here so uh ms
haas if you you indicated in your
testimony that quote every asset listed
on coinbase platform is subject to a
rigorous legal compliance and security
review close quote
could you provide us specific details on
uh on what coinbase's process has been
to be able to make that type of
statement
thank you for the question yes so
specifically for the legal review we
assess each asset under the howey test
where we as brian brooks spoke about
earlier through the crypto ratings
council have established a framework
where we look at the risk factors and we
determine whether or not it it meets
characteristics of the howey test it's a
risk-based assessment it is not a black
and white test but based on our
assessment we believe it's lower risk
that these are securities and before we
list them on our platform we separately
do a compliance review our compliance
review includes looking at the
developers of the token ensuring they're
not on an ofac sanctions list we look at
to make sure it's not a scam that
there's actual people using this coin
that it was developed
in sound manners and then we look at a
security review to understand the
underlying code to say can we provide
custody for this is this at heightened
risk of an attack or someone
pulling the value from these assets so
it's security legal and compliance
before we list an asset okay and i'm
hoping that the chair will grant me
leave for my libor work to just end with
a closing statement as my time is up
here
a number of you have brought up the
unbanked and underbanked and uh despite
rhetoric that gets thrown around all of
us on this committee are very concerned
about it i happen to represent the
second poorest county in the state of
michigan which is in the top 100 poorest
counties in the nation
and i understand what it means for these
unbanked and underbanked folks to be
involved in the process what i want to
make sure is what we do here not just
here today but in the future
we tend to be lag indicators at the
government level and with regulators
rather than on that front end
that front end and i'm hoping that we do
nothing to harm their opportunity to
engage in the process with that i yield
back
thank you very much and thank you for
live war
the gentleman from florida mr lawson is
now recognized for five minutes
uh thank you madam chair and uh
and ranking member henry this is a very
extraordinary meeting and i would like
to again as everyone else welcome
all our people
who are testifying today to
this committee which is very important
i'm not sure
probably would take me a long time to
understand what all we mean about
cryptocurrency and i just heard some
testimonies stating that uh how we lag
behind
all other countries and making changes
and this is to everyone my colleagues
represent
soto and myself and eight other members
of congress
led a letter to leadership addressing
the digital assets provisions that
expand the definition of broker
on the section 6045
for mc1 of the internal revenue code in
1986
to include any person who
for consideration responsible irregular
provision and service of effectiveness
transfer of digital assets on behalf of
another person
as drafted the provision would include
miners and other validated as well as
software and hardware wallet makers who
do not engage in trading activities
and
beyond the scope
of broker services what are your
thoughts on this provision
do you think this is a a good tax policy
to require non-brokers to report on
transaction for people who are not even
their customer why or why not and listen
to the whole committee
maybe i can jump in there congressman
it's brian brooks speaking here just for
a moment i i've said many times that
that language would be sort of like
requiring youtube to get an fcc
broadcast license because they're a
person engaged in distributing
television content i think what we need
to recognize is there's a difference
between centralized exchanges you have
two of the biggest ones represented here
who all agree that they should be
engaged in tax reporting and they do
that versus decentralized algorithms
where there is no company involved in
the transactions at all and there's no
one well situated to provide that kind
of tax reporting so that distinction is
i think super clear the technology has
enabled people to transact peer-to-peer
with no intermediary so who is it that
we're asking to do the trend the tax
reporting in that context
anyone else would like to speak on that
yeah just one this is uh danelle dixon
from the stellar development foundation
one of the
the issues that i think that is a
problem with this is that it may seek to
require these entities that actually
don't have access to any personal
information at all because as the
validators they're actually just
validating the transaction and don't
know who those individuals are that are
on the other side of it it might require
them to gain access to that information
which is exactly what i think many of
you and us do not want
anyone else before i go to the next
question
well this question is from miss i hope i
pronounced this frame it has
uh does
coinbase have multiple lines of business
have multiple lines of business how each
line of business segregated and ranked
fence
from one another to a confidential
information
is not improperly used where confident
confidential information not improperly
used
thank you for the question coinbase does
have multiple products in many cases we
consider our products a product family
where we're serving one customer and the
customer benefits by having those
products within one application so for
example we provide custodial services
which is in for all intents and purposes
a wallet where they can hold their
crypto assets but then integrated with
that is the ability to trade out of that
account
and then to settle new assets back into
that account so those are different
products to be able to store versus be
able to buy or sell but they're
integrated products
those we have within one legal entity as
an example they are offered as one
product family
that is different from when we offer
products such as our coinbase cloud
offering where we're using our
technology to allow others to build in
the crypto economy that data is 100 ring
fenced not
allowed through any of our other
products and we do segregate data we
have different engineers we have
different legal entities we provide a
lot of protection so it depends on the
product that you're speaking about
congressman and some we share and some
are very much ring fenced
okay real quick another question do
withdrawal fees apply to taking crypto
off the platform what fees apply how are
these fees calculated
no we do not charge any fees to withdraw
crypto from our platform
okay with that uh madam chair i yield
back
thank you
the gentleman from arkansas mr hill it's
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair appreciate this
good productive hearing and the good
questions from both sides of the aisle
and appreciate the panel uh being here
uh let me start uh
with uh mr brooks uh
you've had some good comments about uh
the presidential working group on
whether stable coins should be banks or
not but on the issue of the wallet
what should members of congress be
concerned about in sort of that
regulatory umbrella of any individual's
wallet you anticipate
really tens of thousands of wallet
providers or hundreds or and i know in
the working group they suggested it too
should be
a bank or i assume connected to a bank
so is that really necessary and
talk to me about
wallets for our consumers to have access
yeah congressman hill thank you for that
question that that is an important one
and i think as i said earlier the
ability of people to self-custody their
own assets uh and to send them directly
without using an intermediary is at the
core of what we're trying to build so if
we made it so that wallets had to be uh
hosted by a bank or some other regular
institution you know we already have
that we already have banks and that will
take time
committee how things going
i said i'm in committee how things are
going uh mr larson
[Laughter]
please mute you are unmuted please mute
please mute
mr lawson please mute
thank you
okay so so just to finish the thought
meanwhile back at the ranch exactly so
so the ability to self-custody is really
really important my point about the role
of the banking system is simply that
again to my point of parity and an asset
that is or a transaction that's allowed
to be done inside of a bank shouldn't be
technology specific it should be
technology agnostic if your agent
payments are lending you should be able
to do that however but wallets are
critical what's missing from this which
technologists are building today
are crypto native
identification protocols that will allow
us with without getting the name and the
taxpayer id number of the person on the
other side to know that it's a safe
wallet not a blocked wallet and that is
in development today by more yeah i
think that's critical because this you
know we we like the uh the concept of
not being
spied upon by the actions in our wallet
and yet uh we all want to comply with
the rules around aml bsa and so
anonymously securing that the wallet is
in compliance is sort of an important
feature absolutely
ms haas community banks have been the
backbone of course of local our local
markets and critical and in september it
was announced that you partnered with
vast bank with your institution to
provide
uh crypto banking services so
maybe others can comment but let's start
with you uh for aiding a normal
community bank customer out there in my
district or someone who wants to
innovate in a bank and using crypto
products what what uh
are we in a good position regulatory or
are there changes we need to make
i'm going to speak about two things one
i'm going to talk about the how they can
do it and separate we can talk about the
regulatory environment so coinbase has
tools to allow any bank to be able to
provide crypto to their customers where
we want to make our backend services our
nine years of experience of safely
custodying crypto assets and being able
to integrate with blockchains available
to all
global users and one way we do this is
by
letting banks partner with us and white
label our tooling so that they can offer
this directly to their customers
there does need to be continued
innovation and clarity for on behalf of
many banks about what is permissible
activities for them and the banks that
we partner with and speak about their
ability to offer crypto to their end
customers are working with their various
state and federal regulators to gain
clarity about what would be permissible
for them to offer to their end consumers
thank you this is a big deal because
having spent almost four decades in and
out of that business banks are gun shy
about their regulatory burden as mr
brooks certainly knows and
being cleared for that i.t exam or their
new product review exam at their board
level
is really not a something that bank
boards want to be surprised about in
this arena
mr casker
on paxus you have a view on that um
on partnering with banks
yes as uh
maybe some members know we have a number
of partnerships with banks and they work
with us today
i think we're an infrastructure provider
so for us um
banks are important customer set i think
that they're trying to upgrade their
infrastructure to be able to adapt to
this new technology there's a
recognition that
the way the current financial system is
working today is not really adapting to
the 21st century needs of a digital
economy and so i think that there are
important ways in which the current
financial system can upgrade itself uh
traditional assets can now move on
blockchains dollars gold
securities
and it's not just about crypto which as
exciting as it is there's only one piece
of this broader transformation that's
happening
thanks what one what one regulatory
issue would be important to you at that
community bank level and if you would
respond to me in writing thank you i
yield back
thank you
the gentleman from illinois mr foster
who is also the chair of the task force
on artificial intelligence is now
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair and to our
witnesses um i'd like to focus on what i
think is the crucial importance of
having a secure digital identity for
crypto asset transactions uh first
regarding controlled anonymity for a
prevention of criminal activities
and it seems to me that if we wish to
prevent crypto assets from being used
for example for ransomware or other
criminal payments that there is no
logical alternative to having all crypto
transactions associated with a legally
traceable identity
someone who can be extradited if they do
something criminal
and which these can be synonymous to
market participants and to the public
but then must be capable of being
de-anonymized pursuant to the action of
a court in a trusted jurisdiction
do any of you disagree with that
conclusion
that this is a necessary condition for
preventing for example ransomware
so let the record show that they no one
raised objection to that statement so i
think that's very significant so we have
to start planning to for a system where
um in a court in a suitable jurisdiction
can actually de-anonymize any any
legitimate uh crypto asset
okay and now that that is relevant to
to crypto assets such as stable coins or
cdbc's that have stable valuations but
still could be used for criminal
activities but for crypto assets which
are speculatively traded
then we also have an additional worry
which is abusive trading practices in
that case we need to know not only um
the own the beneficial owner behind a
trade but there has to be a uniquely
identified beneficial owner there has to
be a regulator that can see oh this is a
wash trade because you know even though
they look like separate pseudonymous ids
they are in fact the same person um and
and so that you know historically and in
trading that has required to have a
regulator that can see the true
beneficial owners we you know we spent a
decade trying to get the beneficial
owner onto the consolidated audit trail
which probably you're aware of so do you
think that is also a logically necessary
condition to prevent wash trades and
similar abuses
yeah mr bank um yeah i'll say i i do
think that it is and you know we conduct
know your customer diligence on all of
our users so that we do know who the
participants are were responsive to
governmental inquiries about that um
were overseen by the cftc on that with
ftx us derivatives i also think that
this is a powerful argument in favor of
having harmonized regulatory and market
frameworks in particular between
different asset classes where if you end
up with a different regulatory framework
for the market's regulation of bitcoin
bitcoin derivatives stable coins stable
point derivatives
you know uh
ethereum ethereum derivatives and other
assets you end up making it not just uh
riskier and harder and more annoying for
the user to access and more overhead for
the industry but you make it hard to
have consistent regulatory oversight
of a
fractured regime
no i agree completely look it i have
been lurking in the deep weeds for over
a decade and trying to get this split
inside congress and
between the sec and cftc it just you
know this is not something anyone would
have created but
have you had that discussion with yeah a
lot number of you um expressed
enthusiasm for having a single unified
national regulator have you
run that past the egg committee
um
oh look at i know the answer to that i
mean this is this is a one of the
original sins of congress as it's
constituted
and financial services have been
suffering from it for a while um now in
terms of of tax payments it seems to me
that if there was simply the requirement
for any um any
digitally traded asset to be associated
with a pseudonymized uh
basically a tax id that you have an api
provided by the government that says i
want to give me a pseudonymous
tax id and that that be put publicly on
the blockchain then and and that that
blockchain be listed with the tax
authorities that then the tax
authorities could just run a piece of
software and and calculate how much tax
everyone's owed it seems like that's a
very lightweight requirement even on a
startup in this business is there
anything wrong with that concept in
congressman
congressman foster i think i think
you've raised a number of really
critical issues here around
identity
and the importance of that for law
enforcement and and and transparency and
auditability i think it's a critical
area um i i think there's some critical
things that have to be balanced of
course i think uh most of us would agree
i i hope that privacy security
limiting the
leakage of of personal identifiable
information and data breaches these are
real challenges
blockchains provide a very powerful way
to have assured data
they also provide auditability and
transparency and so there's actually a
risk of if you connect too much
personal identifiable information to
these that that could be abused
the only person identify is a
pseudonymous you know you can
cryptographically inspect it make sure
it's valid issued
by uh
you know whatever government you claim
to be domiciled in um has issued this
and then that's all you need to know
i would agree with that i think the
really a critical next step for this
industry are digital identity standards
that allow using cryptographic proofs
using crypto technology itself to prove
that someone has been kyc prove that
someone sure i agree and yeah this is a
we have legislation on that subject and
thank you and i was of course i'm yield
back
thank you the gentleman from minnesota
mr emmer
is now recognized for five minutes
thank you chairwoman waters and thanks
to our witnesses uh for joining us today
uh congress really needs to better
understand the great opportunities that
your businesses are bringing to this
country
mr bankman freed i have several
questions for you and would appreciate
as much as you can quick answers
so we can make the most of the time that
we have ftx us
offers crypto commodity derivatives
products such as futures and options
contracts
to provide these products in the united
states it's my understanding that ftx us
has obtained at least four licenses from
the cftc which you listed in your
testimony that's correct do you know are
there any additional licenses separate
from those four listed in your testimony
that are required by the cftc for ftx
u.s derivatives to be fully compliant
with uh us derivatives regulation
i do not believe so
i think that's correct and uh where does
the price discovery
sir for your cftc regulated crypto
commodity derivatives contracts
primarily come from
so uh there's a very large number of
market participants that um you know
participating those there are hundreds
of billions of dollars per day globally
a volume in similar products and uh like
other markets you know we don't choose
that pricing it's a market-based pricing
that comes from you know a variety of
liquidity buyers market making firms
individual users and other people right
and i mean i'll note
that for bitcoin futures contracts that
uh trade on the uh
cme
which is a cftc regulated exchange
100
of that pricing comes from five u.s
crypto spot exchanges uh bitstamp
coinbase gemini
it bit and uh kraken
we have seen disapproval letters from
the sec on multiple bitcoin spot etf
applications i don't know if you're
aware of that
i the uh uh
chair gensler's justification for not
allowing bitcoin spot etfs to trade is
his belief that bitcoin spot markets are
quote vulnerable to fraud and
manipulation
now it's my understanding that ftx uses
surveillance trade technology akin to
the technology national securities
exchanges use to protect investors and
ensure sound spot markets what does this
technology and any other tools ftx uses
to protect the spot market from fraud
and manipulation look like
yeah so you know like other exchanges we
do have these uh technologies in
addition to the you know know your
customer policies that we can identify
individuals associated with trades we
have surveillance for unusual trading
activity we have manual inspections of
anything that you know gets flagged
either by the automated surveillance or
by manual inspection um and we do this
with the training activity with the
deposits the withdrawals and everything
else
sounds like you're doing a lot to
make sure there is no fraud or other
manipulation i thank you mr bankman
freed
again for helping us understand the
extensive guard rails a cryptocurrency
exchange like ftx has in place to ensure
sound crypto spot markets for investors
the sec has approved several bitcoin
futures etfs that get 100 of their
pricing from u.s crypto spot markets so
i guess i'm left
incredibly confused by how the sec's
concern over spot market vulnerability
applies to bitcoin spot etfs when it
doesn't apply to bitcoin futures etfs
and by the way
this is not a partisan issue i've been
working closely with darren soto on our
blockchain
caucus co-chair on this very issue why
because the bottom line is that
americans deserve access to a wide
diverse range of investment products
they deserve to choose what investment
vehicle they want to put their
hard-earned money into but the sec is
not providing americans uh this choice
when it comes to crypto commodity f etfs
for reasons again
that just don't make a lot of sense
especially after highlighting the
extensive measures crypto exchanges take
to protect their spot markets our strong
crypto and web 3 markets have been
have been uh
in the united states uh have been giving
the united states up incredible capital
market success
these markets are also teeing americans
up for incredible capital formation
opportunities but our regular regulators
simply aren't capitalizing on the
opportunity here and it's my
constituents and all of your
constituents who are taking the hit
because of this and it must change again
i want to thank the witnesses for being
here i hope this is the first of many of
these discussions we have as congress
tries to put together a thoughtful
light touch
guide guide framework
for the industry thank you i yield back
thank you very much we've been joined by
mr sherman from california who's been on
the floor working on his beloved bill
live war and i understand it's been put
up for a vote and we're all looking
forward to voting for this bipartisan
legislation
so this gentleman from california who is
also the chair of the subcommittee on
investor protection entrepreneurship and
capital markets is now recognized for
five minutes
crypto
is many different things
cryptocurrency is an incredibly volatile
investment that aspires to be a currency
that might displace or at least compete
with the dollar
a stable coin
aspires to be incredibly stable and is
tied to the dollar
what they share is a culture
a vibe a stick it to the man moniker
a belief that somehow this is new
and hip
and a attack on the powers of society
but the fact is
that
the ad the
advocates of crypto
represent the powers in our society
uh
um
the powers in our society on wall street
and in washington
have spent millions and are trying to
make billions or trillions in the crypto
world these include goldman sachs jp
morgan visa blackrock citadel
musk and zuckerberg
not to mention the ceos that are before
us here today
uh everyone before us today is a crypto
advocate we will at some point hear from
the crypto
critics
we won't hear from ceos
we hear from academics with their
pencils
and
pens
today we hear from the ceos with their
lobbyists their pacs and their power
and we wonder why we won't be able to
protect investors
the regulators need to listen to this
hearing very carefully
with all the money and power on one side
we will not be able to pass meaningful
legislation don't cop out and say we're
not going to do anything until we pass
meaningful legislation and if you wonder
about where the power is zuckerberg had
to come here himself and sit there
brian armstrong sent his number two
and tether doesn't bother to show up at
all
zuckerberg did not have a day in the
park he did not enjoy it but he had to
come
armstrong didn't and tether ain't here
at all
now
the number one threat to crypto currency
is crypto
bitcoin could be deployed displaced by
ether which could be first placed by
dodge it should be placed by a hamster
coin and then there's cobra coin and
what could [ __ ] coin do to crypto coin
in the area of fiat currency the dollar
will always be more important than the
euro than the uruguayan peso and the
uruguayan peso is not a joke there will
always be an uruguay and the uruguayan
peso will always have some value
will mongo's coin always have a value i
don't know i just made it up it's a joke
although i said that about hamster coin
and then i found out there really was a
hamster coin
um
it's not fair to compare fiat currency's
current system to what crypto currencies
aspire to be
it is true you try to use a credit card
or debit card to buy a sandwich today
the system takes a percent half a
percent 50 cents away from the merchant
you try to use crypto to buy a sandwich
today
i don't know where you can go in
washington to use a bitcoin to buy a
sandwich it can't be done at all
but someday
so we compared to what we hope crypto
can do
to the problems that we face with fiat
currencies now that's not a fair
comparison
now
um looking at uh
uh ms haas from coinbase
if i take a hundred bucks
on your uh exchange
buy some bitcoin
and then couple days later say bitcoin
happens to be selling at the exact same
price i sell it
uh it's my understanding that i get
ninety four dollars and two cents back
am i wrong
we have multiple products and it would
be uh yes or no would i get uh in that
exact transaction ninety four dollars
and two cents back am i wrong
i can't answer the question it depends
on the product
okay are there products where i'd be
right
there is a product where you'd be right
okay so i could lose six bucks in two
days
uh what about tether
buy a hundred bucks worth of tether two
days later sell a hundred bucks worth of
tether or sell the tether could i lose
six bucks
yes
um okay
okay
uh let's turn to uh mr
what
it's a two percent charge
a
two percent charge i thought it would be
a three percent charge it's 2.99 last
time i was on your site no
um
okay um
i'm looking at coinbase fee 299 on us
td
uh we'll put this in the record in any
case
many uh
to lose even two percently let alone
three percent and then another two or
three percent on the way out in scarcely
a couple of days that's well over a
thousand percent interest lost
uh in that period of time uh mr lair um
is your reserves all in um instruments
that yield less
than one tenth of one percent
uh that is correct then how do you pay
one percent interest on some deposits
we don't pay interest on deposits uh and
yet uh you have a uh deal with uh um
uh
my time has expired
thank you very much the gentleman from
georgia mr lotter milk is recognized for
five minutes
well thank you madam chair and uh thank
you for having this hearing i think it's
very intriguing um and and you know very
timely with uh where we are with the
progression of technology i go back and
i think about my 30 years i spent in the
i.t field
had the government got in the way of the
internet we would still be using dial-up
today to do a lot of what we're doing so
i think we have to proceed very
cautiously one thing i've learned in the
30 years in the i.t sector
especially ten years that i spent in the
intelligence realm in the air force
is uh the the most important aspect from
an i.t perspective is data security
cyber security it's something we have to
be focused on all the time in fact in my
business 20 years in the private sector
that was the number one issue for most
of my customers and really got to the
point when i ran for congress of course
i couldn't continue that business i sold
it primarily because i knew that under
the way things were is that the question
wasn't
if
someone was going to be hacked and lose
data it was when and
so
one of the things that i learned when i
was in
in the military is one principle is you
don't have to secure what you don't have
so if you don't need data don't keep it
but then you have the aspect of yes we
have to secure the data that we do need
to keep now this is one thing that the
federal government has yet to learn
is you don't need to acquire a whole lot
of data and keep that data especially
for the federal government which is the
riskiest of anyone out there of of
letting data get out
and then you see more proposals like the
one that we've heard recently with the
craziest proposal is the banks have to
report every transaction by americans
and their banks to the federal
government this is the type of thing
that we don't need to be doing however
there is data that is important that we
do have whether you're in the private
sector whether you're in public sector
and that's where i see the value of the
underlying technology of cryptocurrency
particularly blockchain is a solution to
our cybersecurity problems because of
the distributed ledger aspect of it is
the data is available but is not
centrally located to where it could be
taken
mr brooks
can you discuss how blockchain and
distributed ledger technology can
enhance our cyber security posture
well mr loudermilk is good to see you
and i appreciate the question the
the simplest answer as i said earlier
today is that blockchains are as much
about transparency as they are about
security so one of the biggest problems
when you think about the biggest cyber
hacks we've ever had in the united
states is how long it took for us to
figure out that they occurred the case
of target the case of equifax some of
these things we found out days and weeks
later
by accident that they occurred and if
you think about the equifax hack in
particular initially we thought it was a
small problem weeks later we learned it
was a medium-sized problem and only
months later did we learn it was a
gigantic problem that involved all of
our data
because there was no transparency the
thing about blockchains is every single
block as it is validated is publicly
visible
to the network
the other thing about blockchain is this
based on a consensus mechanism so before
you can have a change to the ledger you
have to have a significant majority of
all of the validators agree that that's
the correct change and so unlike normal
networks where one bad guy can defeat
the entire system here you have to have
thousands of computers agreeing at the
same time that the change can be made
and even then everyone sees it
that hiding on plain sight aspect is the
safest thing about blockchain is why
it's so critical to our security
infrastructure and i think that's one of
the most key
values of this emerging technology is
bringing us into a new era where we can
do some of the things that we need to do
without amassing this data
another area i've been interested in is
is really with payments and i've done
some work
on a related issue with the cfpb's
regulation of remittance transfer so
uh miss dixon
understand that your organization is
active in that space can you describe
how blockchain and dlt are being used to
facilitate payments yeah thank you for
the question this is one of my favorite
topics because it's something that
actually is defining the use case that's
happening today
i think that there are businesses that
transact on the network they can
actually have they can go from the
interoperability with the traditional
financial system is remarkable you can
actually take money from a bank account
put it into digital asset transfer that
value to another to the end wherever
it's being sent and then it can convert
right back into a bank account the fact
that you have such such complete
interoperability with the existing
finance financial infrastructure should
give us all the ability to take like
excitement about elevating that
technology to the right level so that we
continue to innovate there so payments
are something that are constantly being
leveraged on the stellar network they're
done with business payments they're also
done with remittances from the personal
standpoint when you live in california
for example and you want to send money
to your family in another country you
can do so in three to five seconds and a
hundred thousand transactions for less
than a penny on the stellar network it's
a remarkable use of this technology and
this is what can happen if we let
if government doesn't get in the way
of the development of technologies that
benefit the individual and so there are
several other questions i have but i see
my time has uh has expired and i want to
be respectful of everyone so with that
madam chair uh i yield back the room
thank you
the gentlewoman from iowa ms acne who is
also the vice chair of the subcommittee
on housing community development
insurance is now recognized for five
minutes
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
all for being here uh mr bankman freed
i'd like to uh start by asking you the
first question
ftxus has a derivatives platform and
recently bought ledger x as part of that
is that correct yes
okay thank you and that platform is
registered with the cftc is that correct
yep
okay perfect so i just want to clarify
something and this isn't to say
anybody's doing any wrong it's just to
get the lay of the land you also have an
exchange for bitcoin and other tokens
but that is not registered with either
the cftc or the sec is that correct uh
that's correct currently neither of them
are primary miraculous regulators for
spot bitcoin to usd markets
okay thank you and and i know you're
registered as a money transmitter but
that's not the same kind of oversight
that we'll see from a federal market
regulator i also sit on the agriculture
committee which oversees the cftc so a
gap like this is especially concerning
to me and the big problem that i see
here from what i understand is that the
cftc doesn't have regulatory authority
for spot trading of commodities just
their derivatives so that leaves
consumers with inconsistent protections
which is a concern that i have
so mr bankman freed uh you and both ms
haas run exchanges but the investor
protections basically can be whatever
the company separately come up with and
they won't necessarily be the same is
that correct i completely agree with
your worry we do in fact have much the
same investor protections on our spot
markets as on our derivatives markets
but i would be very much supportive of a
similar regime for spot commodities
markets like bitcoin usd markets as we
see for the derivatives markets
very
good
thank you okay so when it comes to
oversight a couple more questions here
do you report your full order history
publicly um
either you mr bankman freed or miss haas
and are there public standards for that
to make sure it's accurate
we do report all of our public market
data it's available on our websites
available via our api we do not charge
anyone anything for it and never intend
to i would be supportive of that
becoming more than just a norm but a
regulatory standard as well
we also make all of our data available
and we do not charge for our data it's
available to our customers okay
and is that order history uh public as
well
yes it is
okay thank you so i just want to make
sure i'm clear on this bitcoin which has
almost a trillion dollars invested in it
has cftc oversight for people to you
know who are trading futures and options
but not for people who are trading the
currency itself is that right
uh that is essentially correct
okay okay so that kind of difference in
protections is really what i want to
focus on here i'm not you know here to
tell anyone what they should or
shouldn't buy they should have crypto or
not have crypto i think there's you know
pros and cons and certainly i've had
plenty of conversations with my own son
who wants to get into crypto uh but i'll
tell you what what i care about is that
when folks do i want to make sure that
they're protected and they've got the
same investor protections that they
would for other forms of currency so i'm
asking can you as an industry and it
sounds like it seems like you can
benefit long term from having more
regulation that sets better standards to
protect investors in this area
yeah i absolutely think so and i think
it's it's you know i'm not concerned
about more regulation i think getting
consumer protection in areas where there
is not currently enough can be extremely
helpful for a robust ecosystem i think
it's just important to do so in a way
that fits the product and in a way that
fits the the regulators as they are
okay thank you for that and i listen i
agree i think it's something that we
absolutely need to look at and i would
certainly ask all of you to think about
the steps that you can take within your
own organizations to make crypto more
safe and trustworthy for investors but i
completely agree with you that we've got
to be doing something to make sure that
we're protecting investors um there are
things that you as exchanges have that
you know that you have to help the
industry long term um
you mentioned that you think we could do
some of these uh regulations and they'd
be good for the long-term growth on
what do you think that could do to help
you build trust and trust for folks in
general for cryptocurrency
and i will say that you know we've had
conversations with um a very large
number of institutional players um you
know
everyone from banks investment banks
pension funds um and this is the number
one thing that comes up is what is the
regulatory framework for the industry
how can we feel that we are protected
both from a commercial standpoint but
also from a regulatory standpoint
in pursuing these options for our
investors and i think it could be
extremely helpful uh you know to clarify
the regulatory frameworks to build them
out where they are are are missing and
to make sure that we have streamlined
and uniform standards that are clearly
communicated
thank you so much for that i'd love to
make sure that crypto is safer and more
trustworthy for investors i yield back
thank you very much the gentleman from
west virginia uh mr mooney is now
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair uh certainly
thankful to the witnesses for being here
appreciate your expertise as we all
learn more about the growing digital
currency issue
back in august of this year the cuban
government announced their central bank
would work
on rules to officially recognize digital
currencies so i'm wondering whether the
country's recent embrace of crypto could
be a way for the communist regime to
evade tough u.s sanctions
so let's start with mr bankman fried
what process does ftx use to ensure that
rogue and frankly murderous autocratic
regimes like cuba cannot use an exchange
to evade united states sanctions
uh we run sanctions checks on all of our
users we conduct uh know your customers
surveillance on them in addition that we
conduct surveillance on the blockchain
and fiat assets that transfer into and
out of our system okay thank you uh i
wanted to ask mrs haas has the same
question proposed the same question you
as it relates to coinbase
largely the same answer we similarly run
ofac tasks on all of our customers both
on onboarding and then ongoing we
believe that sanctions are an effective
tool of the us government in combating
illegal activity in addition to our
onboarding controls we do transaction
monitoring we do surveillance on all of
our transactions on our platform but
also have tools that are looking across
the industry looking and we partner with
law enforcement on investigations
okay so second question uh let me set it
up for you one of the ways that bad
actors or rogue states
could try to fool exchanges is by using
technology like vpn that spoof ip
addresses
fooling others into thinking that
they're in a different location
so let's go with mr brooks on this one
can you speak to the importance of
moving away from ip addresses to verify
location and follow up to that what is
an alternative way of verifying location
well um
a couple of quick answers so on the
compliance side i think the use of vpns
to avoid geolocation and to avoid sort
of geofencing is something that three
years ago was effective and useful and
the industry has developed lots of
technologies that make that much much
harder today
so
you know some of these decentralized
tools several of the companies have been
mentioned already chain alice's elliptic
and some others have an ability to
actually trace ip addresses based on
probabilistic sort of network
information so it's not just that that
ip address might have been issued by an
isp in a given jurisdiction it's also
that that ip address is associated with
lots of other transactions that could
only be cuba or could only be libya or
whatever and the probability assessment
is one of the things that makes this
much easier that's why the network is so
important
okay well thank you i i reference cuba
the cuban government's continued tyranny
is personal for for me and my family my
mother fled communist cuba when she was
20 years old to come the united states
she even rinse he wrote a book about the
horrific experiences in the aftermath of
the revolution there including her time
as a political prisoner in the castro
regime and the marxist cuban government
cannot be allowed to continue to oppress
the cuban people
former president trump's tough sanctions
restricted restrict access to resources
for cuba's rogue government
and i want to work with
the members of this panel to ensure that
the digital marketplace does not enable
the communist cuban regime or other bad
countries around the world who
hate us and and kill their own people
and are tyrannical um hope i'm sure we
all share that goal
i know there are those who think that
that's a role for the federal government
to come in and issue a whole set of
regulations because you can't do it
yourselves
but i think it's better if we work with
you and if you can do it yourselves
better than the federal government that
might be the answer so thank you madam
chair and i yield back the balance of my
time thank you the gentleman from new
york mr gothheimer who is also the vice
chair of the subcommittee on national
security international development and
monetary policy is now recognized for
five minutes
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
for uh all our panels for being here
today very grateful
if i can start with mr bankman freed
uh first please
from my role on the national security
subcommittee at on financial services
i'm committed to ensuring bad actors
like terrorists and drug dealers cannot
access the financial services sector for
purposes contrary to us interests
and while
obviously i support cryptocurrency and
potential benefits in the digital
payment space one area remains
particularly concerning for me the theft
of cryptocurrency and its potential use
and illicit or terrorist financing these
issues are also related in so far as
stolen funds may be used for nefarious
purposes i introduced my bill h.r 3685
the hamas international financing
prevention act in part because of the
increased reporting around the use of
cryptocurrency donations to support
hamas
two questions if you don't mind first
what are exchanges doing today to both
ensure that consumers are protected from
hacking and theft and to prevent bad
actors such as hamas and other terrorist
organizations from accessing uh
cryptocurrency markets uh and what
context too well what context would you
flag a transaction to law enforcement
and have you ever flagged transactions
for law enforcement agencies
yeah so uh i guess i'll first briefly
talk about the security aspect of this
about stopping breaches to accounts
where we mandate that all users have
two-factor authentication for all of
their accounts with a very broad suite
of security uh practices that all users
can access on the site um in addition to
all of the know your customer policies
um on the bad actor side you know we
conduct kyc surveillance on all users of
the
exchange we do that on all deposits and
withdrawals using multiple tools on the
blockchain and for fiat currencies and
uh you know to address that and care
question about law enforcement we work
cooperatively with law enforcement here
in the united states and globally on uh
you know tracking down any bad actors we
are in constant communication um we
strive to be as helpful as we can be the
combination of the uh near customer
surveillance that we do plus the
transparency of the public ledgers of
blockchains actually can make it a
really powerful tool for tracking down
any funds um from illicit activity um
we've used that we have been you know
participating in in uh phrasing a
substantial amount of assets on our
platform um in cooperation with law
enforcement and you know look forward to
continuing to uh to work with them
globally
thank you so much
uh mr o'lair
the president's working group's recent
paper on stable coins included a
recommendation that all stable coin
issuers be required to become
insured depository institutions such as
banks i understand that circle has
stated that it intends to become a bank
but currently
backs the ustc in circulation one-to-one
with reserves held at partner banks
i'm working on a bill that could
potentially implement a number of these
recommendations
if i can ask do you think it is
necessary for safety and soundness for
stablecoin issuers to themselves be
insured depository institutions or if
partnering with insured depository
institutions sufficient and what are the
pros and cons of each model please
thank you for the question congressman
um
i think it's a very important issue um
as noted we have decided to pursue a
national bank charter and are open to
being an fdic insured bank as well i
think it it
however there's some subtlety in this in
this topic and i think it's important
for the committee to consider it
a full reserve
digital currency model such as usdc
where 100 of the assets are fully
reserved in high quality liquid assets
such as cash uh and uh and short
duration us treasuries
is not the same as a bank deposit where
the bank is in turn taking the deposit
and rehypothecating it and lending it
and and really the purpose of fdic
insurance is for that fractional reserve
lending that takes place and so i think
the real question in our minds is um i
think it can be really powerful for a
stablecoin issuer to have a federal bank
charter
to be able to access the fed and hold
cash at the fed in terms of the ultimate
form of safety and soundness for those
cash assets
but not necessarily being lending banks
that are rehypothecating capital the
form of insurance perhaps could be uh
investigated i know that the fdic
itself has been thinking about what are
potential uh appropriate forms of
insurance on stablecoin issuers and so i
think it's a live issue
but just applying the kind of apples to
apples
model on a full reserve banking model
i think does raise some questions so i
think ultimately coming back to your
question um
i think that
you know statutes in the united states
should support stablecoin issuers that
are operating at a state level at a
federal level
and support money services businesses as
well as banks uh being active
participants in in the stablecoin
ecosystem and i i think it's important
that uh the barrier to entry in the
stablecoin space not be so high that
startups that are innovating as money
services businesses uh can't participate
in this innovation
thank you so much and i yield back thank
you
the gentleman from north carolina mr
budd is now recognized for five
i think the chair
the united states has a huge opportunity
with crypto
but my fear is that this regulatory
state
it's going to crack down on an industry
that the regulators
they really don't understand yet and
it's going to force the next generation
of
financial tech to be created outside of
our country
well we can't let that happen so mr
brooks it's good to see you again
where do companies draw the line and say
that enough is enough
with this
anti-innovation
quote regulation by enforcement
and then just decide to take their
industry elsewhere to another country
where's the line
well mr butt it's good to see you and
thank you for that question what i would
say is in some aspects of the industry
the line is super clear there are some
products that are legal in other
countries and are just not legal here so
i take some of the investment products
we've talked about earlier today for
example exchange traded funds
one of the things that makes crypto
risky is that consumers may not
understand the difference between one
token and another token and so they may
want to diversify much as i own an s p
500 mutual fund we don't allow that in
the united states we do allow it in
canada we allow it in germany singapore
portugal and a number of other places so
if you're a developer of those products
there's no fuzzy line it's super clear
you can't do that here so you have to go
abroad okay there are some other people
can you say why we can't do that here
sure it's because the securities and
exchange commission has consistently
refused to approve products that other
g20 nations have approved so we're
behind the curve
unquestionably
so given your previous experience
running the occ i'd love to hear your
perspective on where a regulator where a
regulator's authority begins
and ends
remember the joke earlier this year that
everything's infrastructure well um it
seems like chairman gensler thinks that
everything is a digital asset that he
can regulate
he cites the howie and the reeves test
without providing any other explanations
so mr brooks what are we missing because
chairman gensler clearly doesn't see a
limit to his regulatory authority in
this area
well congressman one thing i learned
running you know my my little agency is
that the us and this is not specific to
crypto the us is sort of unique among
the developed countries in our
fragmented approach to regulation so so
when i hear people talk about the idea
that we need one regulator for crypto i
would say we should first have one
regulator for banks but we have three of
them or if you're an investment bank
five of them
so that's inherent in the system that
we've got what i say to that is the last
thing we need to do is add another
regulator to a system that's already got
dozens of regulators what we need to do
instead is have parity for crypto
activity along with traditional finance
if i'm a crypto lending platform i
should probably be regulated by the fdic
if i'm a crypto trading platform i
should probably be regulated by the cftc
and sec
but somehow we treat crypto because it's
new
as different from everything else and
i'm going to argue that crypto is just a
step function improvement in the system
we already have a regulatory system the
laws are super clear how it works but
there's something about crypto that
scares people i don't know what it is
maybe it's just because it's new but i
remember in my banking law class when
banks were first allowed to use
computers to keep ledgers people sued
over that at the time i remember when i
was a second year lawyer and we got
email and the aba said lawyers couldn't
use email because it would travel over
this mysterious network of computers
these all seem ridiculous
today but it seems like we haven't
really learned the underlying lesson
which is technology usually advances
human flourishing we have a regulatory
system let's use it
thank you for that miss haas as you're
aware the infrastructure bill was signed
into law last month and had lots of
problems
for digital assets so i was very vocal
about a need for a fix for this and i
was proudly supporting ranking member
mchenry's bill
to make those fixes so would you please
address some of your concerns and why
those flaws would be so bad for the
crypto community
thank you and thank you for your support
on this important bill so first of all i
want to make it clear that coinbase
supports tax payments in crypto we think
that everybody should be paying their
taxes and we think that centralized
entities like coinbase should be
reporting no different than a schwab no
different than a fidelity it's important
value-added service for our customers
but what concerned us about the drafting
of the infrastructure bill specifically
to the tax provisions was that these are
complex issues crypto taxation is
complex the technology has new players
in the space
and that we didn't have
the common public comment period that we
would typically have for something so
complex and so what happened was the
risk of an unintended consequence and i
think that we can still solve this i
think that we are not to the place that
it could be scary but the definition of
a broker was potentially overly wide and
could be interpreted to include
players such as miners such as the
hardware wallets that do not have access
to this information that have no ability
to comply with reporting regimes and
then could be
consequence there could be penalties
there could be federal risk to them so
we thought it was overly broad and then
separately in 605 oi we thought that
there was additional reporting risk that
was privacy and also could be deemed
overly broad and pull in parties that
were not necessarily
deemed to be covered by this rule
thank you very much chair i yield back
thank you very much i think you need to
make a correction you refer to uh
mr um
mr brooks
as uh having been at sec
and he has been saying over all along he
was at occ okay i never made that
reference but thank you
well all right thank you very much we
appreciate your presence here today and
your expertise in
banking law thank you
the gentleman from massachusetts mr
lynch who is also the chair of the task
force on financial technology is now
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair great hearing i
want to thank all of our witnesses as
well
prior to
the creation of the subcommittee
on financial services we had a terrorist
financing task force that i chaired for
about eight years so
um i'm keenly
uh sensitive to the issues around know
your customer and aml
and uh i worked a lot with uh fincen the
financial crimes enforcement network
on
traditional banking protections uh with
regard to terrorist financing and money
laundering
and i know that at the end of last year
fincen
actually
issued a rule-making proposal to require
banks and money service businesses
to submit
reports and verify the identity of
customers involved
uh with wallets uh for virtual currency
and so uh this particular rule making uh
focus
uh on those wallets that were
hosted in in low compliance
jurisdictions
and uh were identified by fincen
as as walks which were not hosted by a
financial institution called unhosted
wallets
and uh
the requirements that fincen came up
with are sort of similar to what we use
now for
uh money transmitters so uh mr armstrong
and mr elaire uh your firms in
particular were vocally opposed to that
rule making and and i i heard your
responses to mr foster and to others uh
regarding identity and i just i want to
try to understand can you share why uh
the transactions
involving virtual assets and payments
involving those wallets
uh that are quite similar uh to western
union transmissions or or moneygrams
why you objected to
what looks like a fairly similar
regulatory uh
approach
mr elaire if you might take a crack at
it
thank you congressman lynch for the
question it's a very important question
um you know first i i would simply start
by saying
i think fincen has done an excellent job
at looking at the issues of of money
laundering terrorist financing in the
context of virtual assets virtual
currencies they led the way as the first
federal regulator to in fact put in
place rules around that back in uh 2013
that led firms like circle coinbase and
many others here to uh put in place
licensing supervision around bank
secrecy act uh any money laundering
provisions and the like um i think the
specific issue at hand uh which uh you
are correct uh we had some significant
objections to
was
was really twofold one was there was a
introduction of a 11th hour rulemaking
that did not have a significant public
comment and i think at the at the bottom
of that issue is
there are some really significant things
about the way digital assets and
blockchains work
that we want to make sure if we're going
to
be introducing rules around reporting
that they take
they take account of the unique things
with with public blockchain
infrastructures in particular
notably public blockchain
infrastructures are in some ways like
the public internet or the world wide
web or email they're open networks that
anyone can connect to join and use and
it's one of the really powerful things
that has made information exchange free
and i think it's one of the things that
we believe with digital assets on
blockchains can make value exchange much
more frictionless for people around the
world
and a part of that is that there are
you know the ability for an individual
to self-custody assets with a piece of
hardware or piece of software that piece
of software could be downloaded from an
app store
and they're self-custing uh a stable
coin like usdc or bitcoin um and that's
the software maker itself is not
involved in facilitating uh a customer
transaction they're really just
a software developer providing
technology that end users can use and i
think the the rule as it was outlined
would kind of be a square peg round hole
or a bit of a blunt force instrument and
what we argued and and i think is is
hopefully going to bear fruit
significantly over the next year is that
what we really need are ways to uh
provide proof of digital identities a a
a firm like circle or a firm like ftx or
coinbase or paxos or other members other
folks testifying here could provide a
cryptographic proof that someone has
been kyc'ed and that proof could
actually be carried around with them in
a hardware wallet or a software wallet
and then you'd have the ability to
know that you've got legitimate actors
to be able to have the right information
about users
without having
essentially more pii or personal
identifiable information being
broadcasted really broadly and so i
think our view was give the industry
more time to develop technology that can
allow these forms of transactions to
happen but still preserve privacy and
take advantage of the really significant
security benefits that come from
cryptography
okay that's that's fair i know uh my
time has expired so uh thank you madam
chair i yield back thank you
uh the gentleman from tennessee mr
kustoff is now recognized for five
minutes
thank you madam chairman thank you also
for convening today's hearing
thank you to the witnesses i i know
we've been here for for some time but
it's been very informative and and i
appreciate it and i know we all do
this house if i if i could with you
could i could we talk about the uh about
the crypto rating council
that i believe coinbase and other
industry players
created to determine what digital assets
look more like securities and which ones
don't
if you could
could you talk to me about how the
council
makes its determination and who's
involved in the process
thank you for the question so the crypto
rating council is an independent entity
that works to serve industry
participants such as coinbase with an
assessment of digital assets underneath
the howey test so it's looking at the
white papers that new
asset projects put forth
and making a determination under the
howie test whether or not that new
project
is more likely than not to meet the
definition of a security under u.s
federal securities laws
independent law firms are the ones who
are doing this assessment who are u.s
securities laws experts and looking at
facts and circumstances to make an
assessment
thank you
if i could ask you could you
you talked about
securities can you talk about
what degree if any of the sec and other
stakeholders have been involved in what
the discussions have been
with in terms of the framework
thank you for the opportunity to address
this
so at this point in time the sec has not
provided a clear definition
about what is or is not a security
they've asked us to rely on the howie
and reeves test and we companies like
coinbase companies like ftx and others
pay careful attention to ongoing
litigation that is existing in the space
news that we see but we are left to
interpret based on our interpretation of
law
for what is and is not a security at
this time
thank you mrs mr brooks uh if i could to
you thank you also for for being here
if i could i think there are obviously
there are people
who believe that cryptocurrency is
difficult maybe even impossible to to
track
can you talk about that as it relates to
the to the blockchain and and
while
we talk about illicit activities
legislative activities
oftentimes would be investigated by
federal authorities
could you explain maybe the fallacy of
that is if you were talking to our local
police chiefs or local sheriffs
sure well thank you for the question mr
kossoff i actually do this talk at local
rotary clubs and things around the
country all the time so i think i can do
that pretty well
i think the easiest way to understand it
is let's contrast blockchain
transactions with normal banking
transactions to see how much easier it
is to trace them on a blockchain than it
is in a banking transaction so
let's imagine for a moment that uh
i would never do this because this would
be flagrantly illegal but let's say i
bought you lunch okay and let's say that
afterwards uh you wanted to venmo me
your payment back right so you hit your
venmo button on your iphone
and you sent me money
what many people don't understand is
that there are seven or eight different
steps in the venmo transaction so all
venmo does is send an instruction to
your bank
your bank then receives that instruction
they write it down in their books and
records and then they then send an
instruction to an underlying transfer
network it could be the automated
clearinghouse could be the fed wire
system or something else
that system then contacts my bank it
inquires whether my bank has enough
money to pay you once that's been done
then there's a debit from my account
it's very complicated and in any one of
those steps information could be lost
there could be a breach something bad
could happen
versus in a blockchain there are no
intermediaries i'm not sending
instructions to a third party to send
instructions to another third party to
eventually send you money i've sent you
money and when the block is validated i
can see that my wallet address
transferred that value to your wallet
address simple as that the easiest way
for people to understand how easy this
is because we've had a lot of talk of
hacking and cyber security issues
the reason that we found the bad guys in
the colonial pipeline hack
was because they asked for bitcoin if
they had asked for diamonds if they had
asked for cash if they'd asked for
almost any other thing we'd never have
caught the bad guys we caught the bad
guys because not in spite of because
they used bitcoin and we could tell
exactly where the money went
uh
so
the blockchain because the blockchain
was used it was traceable correct
and just briefly because my time is
expiring
again as you're talking to rotary clubs
you could give specific
examples where the fbi and other federal
law enforcement agencies use the
blockchain in fact to help trace and
help determine when i used to work at
coinbase i ran a group
that
facilitated those customers they were
our clients we did work for them
thank you very much i yield back
thank you the gentlewoman from north
carolina
ms adams is now recognized for five
minutes
thank you chairwoman waters uh to
ranking member mchenry both of you for
hosting the hearing uh mr
uh pasquerilla
uh i wanna touch briefly on the risk
that stable horns might pose to our
border financial system the president's
working group report which we spent
plenty of time talking about today
expressed concern that any perceived
instability could trigger a run-on
on that uh stable coin in 2008 we saw
the dangers of instability and prime
money mark uh funds and now rating
agencies are saying that so how do you
respond to the assertion by the
president's working group that that'll
run on stable coins could cause systemic
instability
uh thank you for the question i think uh
this is a crucial uh topic when it comes
to stable coins
i think the key point here is to define
stablecoin
and uh
depending on how you define it it
creates different risks if a stablecoin
is backed by only cash and cash
equivalents
essentially money that's sitting in an
fdic insured bank account or sitting in
uh t bills that mature in three months
there is no risk of a run
it's liquid cash you've taken simply a
dollar and you've tokenized it
and
there's very good uses for that and
there's really good reasons to set it up
that way of course you could decide to
back your stablecoin with other assets
and certain issuers do it could be loans
it could be
cds it also could be
other types of securities and in that
case you start to have
um not really a stable coin but you have
something that looks more like maybe a
bank deposit in that case it would make
a lot of sense i think for
a banking regulatory regime to oversee
it and also it could be that it looks
more like a money market fund because
it's backed by certain types of
securities and it would make sense for
the sec to oversee it
so we are a trust company okay i was
going to ask how stable coins are not
similar to market uh money market funds
but i think we've
you've made some clarification there so
mr haas
uh in october of this year coinbase
released an operational framework of the
digital asset uh policy proposal in
which you and
would you advocate for the creation of a
new self-regulatory organization you
indicate that
incorporating uh an sro into the
regulatory supervision
of marketplaces will speed the
development and enforcement of an
appropriately tailored digital asset
industry rule
uh so in your view how can congress and
industry best come together to begin
laying the foundation for a successful
regulatory framework for digital asset
trading platforms such as yours thank
you so much for this question so i want
to clarify that first on our proposal we
are seeking one single federal regulator
it could be an existing federal
regulator we're not asking for the
creation of a new federal regulator and
the value that we think of having an sro
would be this is complex there is new
innovation happening in crypto every
single day we haven't even touched on
nfts or dows in this committee hearing
today and we think it's important that
there's a nimble group that is
constantly looking at the changes in
crypto and so that's why we recommended
having an sro in addition to a single
federal regulator
the way that we would love to work with
you all is we think there's a this is an
important step in the process we think
that this hearing is important but we
really believe that having policy makers
deeply understand the technology getting
input from the industry understanding
the use cases will help craft prudent
regulation here we believe that we agree
with you all on first principles of
regulation but the how we get there is
going to look very different in crypto
than it has in our traditional financial
markets that relied on intermediaries i
think many of the testimonies on this
panel have spoken very similarly about
the challenges we see and we'd love to
work with you in partnership
thank you ma'am uh this is to all the
witnesses and it can be a yes or no
would you commit to we as a two-time
hbcu graduate i care deeply about making
sure that your companies reflect the
diversity of our country so yes or no
would you commit to sharing data about
the racial and gender makeup of your
companies
i want everyone if you can to answer it
quickly yes or no
are are you committed to doing that
all right yes yes yes we'd be happy to
connect with your office
well great we would appreciate that very
much it is a
concern of not only this committee
but certainly of
one of our co-chairs uh
joyce beatty and myself and some others
so
thank you very much and and thank you
for your responses and madam chair i'm
going to yield back thank you
the gentleman from indiana mr
hollingsworth is now recognized for five
minutes
well good afternoon i appreciate
everyone being here and certainly
appreciate the dialogue that has been
engendered thus far
i will admit to you my air edition on
such matters is very very low and so i'm
on a genuine fact-finding mission
not on a confirmation of my preconceived
notions about how this could be used or
alternatively how it should be treated
by regulators
i think specifically to
uh mr alaire to start with would you
define stable coin for me
sure thank you for the question
congressman
there are many types of stable coins
right um there are
stable coins are called stable coins
because they are intended to
hold a stable value i think the name can
you can you clarify and be more specific
stable value relative to what
well relative to some underlying
reference assets right but that
reference asset in and of itself may in
fact be volatile right if i said this
had 100 correlation with one ounce of
gold right that would be stable relative
to a gold but not stable relative in an
absolute sense that's exactly right so
say the purchasing power of a dollar uh
is changing rapidly with inflation and
so or in other countries hyperinflation
uh or there's deflationary assets and so
on so the reference asset obviously has
a huge impact you brought this up and i
wanted to delve further into that i
appreciate that so a lot not a lot maybe
not even the minor the majority some
non-trivial portion of stable coins are
backed by u.s dollars and are
um transferable to and from dollars
right
so
in essence explain to me
the value proposition to me owning a
stable coin that i can convert into
dollars as opposed to owning the dollars
themselves what's the value proposition
to a consumer
yeah it's a really great question um and
i think it's good to use analogies
sometimes on this right it's sort of
like the difference between having a a
postal letter versus an email a digital
version of a letter can move it the
speed of the internet to anyone for free
right that's really an upgrade to the
functionality of a letter for example so
digital music the same kind of attribute
so digital currency dollars inherit the
kind of superpowers of the internet the
speed uh the reach right the
interoperability yeah net summary of
that right is it is no different as a
store of value than owning dollars right
because it is convertible to and from
dollars but it's different in its
transaction characteristics right it can
move faster and presumably at a cheaper
cost of transaction than perhaps
transacting in dollars is that a fair
way to say that i think that's basically
correct although i'd say
well-designed stable coins are safer
than bank deposits because bank deposits
you're taking a risk on the lending book
of the underlying bank
and so you have run risk you have
default risks of all of the deposits and
loans that might sit in a bank a full
reserve form of money which is what a
dollar digital currency such as usdc
represents is actually a safer form to
hold not just store value but as a
transactional medium as well right
assuming that you hold your dollars in a
bank account that's right yeah there is
some level of counterparty risk we have
worked hard frankly in this country into
a regulatory environment of minimizing
that and through federal government
guarantees but that remains non-zero if
trivial right so walk me through the
transaction value
of owning a stable coin right and here's
my view just outside of this right i
understand the notion that
if i go to a retailer that accepts that
stable coin right then i can transact
with them presumably at a lower cost
that retailer hopefully my prices are
lower on account of that and i can
transact faster with them but there is a
non-zero transaction cost associated
with getting into that stable coin right
so i've kind of traded this notion of
accelerating my pace of transaction
lowering the cost once i get into the
system but there are costs to get into
the system right i have to buy whatever
that stable coin is from dollars right
yeah so um in i can speak in the case of
of usdc
so if an institution wants to uh
transfer dollars into usdc we don't
charge a fee for that and uh i have to
get set up to do so right now i can't
just go and get a debit card use my
debit card out of my bank account i have
to set up an account right presumably
you have some process by which i do that
once i get over that hurdle then i can
transact that inside that that's correct
and and i think many users of stable
coins um keep their value in stable
coins because they are now able to use a
very very efficient payment and
settlement medium so that's attributed
uh to the you know the the high growth
that you've seen is partially attributed
to that so is the value proposition that
the this network of those that accept
this is going to expand some more people
are going to keep that in stable coins
and then my second question is going to
be
why can't the same technology that runs
stable coins eventually run the payment
system in dollars
right what won't we eventually cut out
the middle step of having to convert to
a stable coin and then transact in this
frictionless and speedier environment
won't we eventually have to figure out
run that through the existing payment
system well i i think there's there's
two two points here so one is um you
know dollar digital currencies like usdc
are both kind of protocols and and are a
form of representation a form factor for
a dollar and there are network effects
there just like there are network
effects and other internet protocols
that we use for things and and i think
that's significant to this to the second
um question
i think it's in some ways it's a it's a
question of semantics when i uh use uh
the the iou settlement system of a of a
visa card i'm not actually like spending
dollars per say i'm i'm there's a bunch
of ious that are on a centralized ledger
that are keeping track of things then
ultimately underneath there's a fed wire
that goes from one bank to another
we experience it as well this is this
card and there's a whole elaborate kind
of system underneath that that charges
fees i think um what we see you know
well-regulated stable coins are an
upgrade to those kinds of payment
systems to be ready for the internet era
i appreciate the chairs thank you the
gentleman's time has expired the
gentlewoman from new york ms
ocasio-cortez
is now recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair and thank you to
all of our witnesses who are here today
at this hearing um before i get into the
heart of my question of my questions
today um there was a slight discrepancy
in some of
the the testimony and questioning from
earlier today i just wanted uh miss haas
to to clarify very quickly um earlier
today
in the hearing representative velasquez
asked about proprietary trading uh on
the coinbase platform
and
in that moment you i believe you had uh
told her quote uh that coinbase does not
engage in proprietary trading on our
platform all prices are established etc
um however
in looking at the coinbase rules under
section 3.21 under coinbase corporate
ops it says
coinbase inc which owns and operates
coinbase pro and exchange
also trades its own corporate funds on
coinbase pro and exchange and i just
wanted to give you uh briefly the
opportunity to
to clarify thank you so much for the
opportunity to clarify
there's a few things that we do in our
business so one is we do have a
corporate investment portfolio that
every month we make an investment of
crypto and add to our balance sheet
we've not sold that we don't trade it
actively but we do increase the
investment on a monthly basis on
pre-established investment protocols we
do buy those on our exchange got it
understood thank you very much um so to
the heart of the matter
crypto as we know is growing industry
it's rising in market value from 500
billion last year to more than three
trillion as of uh november of of this
year 2021. um you know there are a lot
of uh you know advocates proponents
of the cryptocurrency industry that
discuss
the creation of a new digital creation
of new digital currencies i should say
and then building safer more inclusive
system outside of the traditional
financial sector um but i kind of want
to explore this uh assertion a little
bit more
mr elaire a substantial portion of the
buying and selling of cryptocurrencies
is done with stable coins correct
a significant amount is traded with
stable coins yes it's about 75 percent
uh does that sound about right to you
uh i don't have the data in front of me
but it does sound okay correct uh and
these stable coins are designed to be
backed by certain reserve assets whether
they are primarily usd
um or safe highly liquid cash
substitutes essentially a coin to be
stable in value
so that people can kind of um
use it in a larger world of crypto where
other coins could perhaps be a little
bit more volatile on their value
i i can certainly speak to the design of
usdc i certainly i can't really speak to
others so yes usdc is designed
as a payment instrument under electronic
money you know law in the united states
and so it's uh you know cash and short
duration u.s government treasuries uh
which is the underlying instruments for
the stored value in fact your firm
recently announced a transition to
one-to-one backing in dollars of usd
coin after it was found that only 60 of
the coin was backed by cash or cash
substitutes
so if the cryptocurrency
industry
hypothetically
lost its ability to use stable coins as
a bridge to trade in
to trade in and out of dollars
tomorrow
would
that cause a significant shift you know
it
it seems as though it would not be able
to work the way that it uh does
currently correct
well i think i think you know a primary
reason why stable coins are are so
powerful is that they're they're a
superior form of settlement um and so
the existing banking system moves slowly
uh funds take several days for them to
move and there are significant fees and
the access to that can be limited
whereas blockchains operate continuously
and settlement happens at the speed of
the internet and so um i think it is
important that uh payments and
settlement in this this new these new
forms of internet financial products and
services can operate at the speed of the
internet so i think it's essential i see
thank you and and so leslie what would
you say to some of the folks
who are listening to uh what some folks
are saying not just here on this panel
but
in the larger world um so the folks that
say what do you say to the folks that
say basically
this doesn't seem like a new financial
system per se but really an extension
or perhaps expansion of our present one
well i i would disagree with that um i
think
what what i believe we're seeing is a
new
open infrastructure layer on the
internet a missing infrastructure layer
of the internet that is designed around
value exchange and economic coordination
that is rooted in
you know immutable data the ability to
interact with counterparties in a very
very safe way that hasn't existed before
on the internet
and really many of the um
efficiencies that the internet brings in
terms of moving information brought into
moving value
but also with greater degrees of
security than are often offered to the
existing financial system so i really do
believe we're building a new global
economic infrastructure layer uh and
we're working you would say that that's
not distinct you would you would argue
that that is distinct
uh not an expansion or an increase in
the sophistication of our current
financial system uh i believe you know
for this to take uh take hold it needs
to be well integrated with our existing
financial system and we've we've long uh
believed in a kind of hybrid model that
does that thank you very much
thank you the gentlelady's time has
expired the gentleman from ohio mr
gonzalez is now recognized for five
minutes thank you madam chair i truly
appreciate this hearing this is a great
hearing i want to start with mr brooks
and i'm going to attempt to respond to
some of the objections which i believe
demonstrate a complete and utter
misunderstanding of what we're even
doing here today
uh one contention is that the vibe of
crypto is a stick it to the man vibe but
in actuality it's dominated and
controlled by big tech and wall street
while the culture may be somewhat
accurately described the notion that a
handful of big tech leaders in wall
street banks somehow created and now
control crypto
is absurd on its face and
frankly anyone who would make such a
claim i believe should be ignored on
this topic
my contention is that web3 crypto
blockchain etc by its very structure has
the ability to solve some of the most
difficult and frustrating problems that
the current version of the internet and
the financial system have where a narrow
set of platforms control what we see how
we interact and what we buy while
millions of americans remain completely
disconnected from the financial system
web3 can turn this entire thing on its
head in a very empowering way so my
question's simple how specifically could
you see web3 solving some of these
bigger challenges associated with the
current version of the internet and the
financial system
well congressman gonzalez thanks for the
for the question when i go back to the
criticisms that you're just recounting
the only part of that i heard was hip
i'm going with hip the rest of it you
know we can come to
but in terms of the problems being
solved i i think the first issue is the
biggest critics of cryptocurrency have
been the biggest banks
those are the people who are the most
concerned about the entry of stable
coins into the payment system about the
ability of crypto assets to build
networks that are away from the
clearinghouse
those are the biggest critics and so i
think that that tells you a lot of what
you need to know and the reason is
because the way that web3 solves a lot
of problems it's really two-fold first
of all it eliminates the toll collector
role of traditional banks and
traditional broker-dealers the main
thing that they do
is they employ large numbers of human
beings maintaining ledgers of account
and allocating credit for a fee
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies do
that without human beings and with no
fee and the elimination of minimum
account balance fees the 25 dollar wire
transfer fee that your bank charges to
give you three days to send money abroad
those are gone
that's what's important but the last
part is it unlocks value the traditional
economic structures don't unlock the
creator economy play to earn in the
gaming system those don't exist so i
want to go to ms haas on that uh
building off this in your testimony you
mentioned use cases for web3
in the creator and gaming economies
could you please outline a specific use
case and discuss how web3 can empower
creators and artists over mega tech
platforms which was implied earlier
and quickly please if you could all
right let's talk really quickly i'll
cite the one that we just talked about
earlier which is in the month of
november play to earn so these are where
video games one can play a video game
and earn nfts those nfts are in-game
experiences so if anyone here has young
kids who are playing with roblox playing
with minecraft playing with these
there's in-game experiences where you
can buy avatars you can buy various
things these can become nfts these nfts
then can be sold for value and so what
we're having here is these kind of the
concept of a play to earn you can play
the video game you can earn money you
can then monetize that back into fiat
and you can create these new economies
and these new communities that have
increasing value thank you
uh mr bankman freed i believe you live
in hong kong is that correct
hey sir you've read that do you live in
hong kong is that correct uh i do not
anymore oh okay um well let me ask the
question i did at one point
so 10 years ago certainly 20 30 years
ago if you wanted to start a major
internet company you probably wanted to
do it in the united states you probably
wanted to do it where you grew up uh in
in stanford on
on the coast in silicon valley for a
whole host of reasons one of which being
a
very very conducive innovative
environment
when i look at web3 i see a lot of
projects moving overseas
to what degree is the current regulatory
environment in the united states
contributing to this change where
projects are now being built and
domiciled in nations not the united
states
whereas in the previous versions of the
internet they were
i do think it has contributed to that
i'm optimistic that we're going to see
uh changes in the framework over the
next few years that will bring us into a
world that can make the united states
the source of the deepest and most
liquid markets in the cryptocurrency
ecosystem i don't think we've seen that
historically and if you look at the you
know difference between the volume
distribution of crypto
and digital assets versus most other
industries you can see that mr brooks do
you have any thoughts on that
well uh congressman as i said earlier
there are certain activities that
our g20 partners seem to think are
perfectly appropriate legitimate and
subject to regulation and we keep
resisting those have moved abroad
uh thank you and thank you madam chair i
yield back
thank you the gentlewoman from michigan
miss talib is now recognized for five
minutes
thank you madam chair and thank you so
much uh for everyone to um
that have been coming forward in regards
to this important issue
uh you know cryptocurrency
like bitcoin currently consumes enough
energy to power a small nation and
that's something that
continues to be missed in this debate
around this issue and you know the
university of cambridge um analysis
estimated that bitcoin mining consumes
121
um terawatts hours a year to put that in
perspective
for everyone
that's more electricity than the entire
country argentina consumes that's more
than the consumption of google apple
facebook and microsoft combined
one bitcoin transaction a single
purchase sale or transfer uses the same
amount of electricity as the typical u.s
household uses in more than a month
and so this is really outstanding to me
and many folks do not
uh know this many americans and folks
that are talking about this issue and so
miss dickson can you explain why for a
cryptocurrency like bitcoin that rely on
proof of work model mining
is such an energy intensive process
thank you for the question this is a
really important area obviously in terms
of sustainability and uh the focus on
what we do in this space we should
always be trying to do it better and
much more efficiently uh the in bitcoin
is the proof of the the way that bitcoin
consensus is achieved is through uh
really complicated math equations and so
there's a lot of energy that's needed to
be used to be able to make that happen
i know best about the the consensus
mechanism on stellar which is the
stellar consensus protocol which can be
done on a very small computer any of the
ones that you have in front of you and
the uh it you can see we had a
university of london did a study on the
stellar network itself and the uh
network is is low in terms of energy
consumption it's around point zero zero
zero two two kilowatts per hour for each
transaction that's less than a
transaction for visa so that's a really
important comparison for us all to think
about so not every consensus mechanism
is proof of work or proof of stake again
there are many many different ones out
there and depending on the mechanism it
depends on the energy consumption but
it's definitely important for us to be
able to try to do this better more
efficiently and to consider the
sustainability concerns around it
no i'm so glad you talked about model
that potentially you know to shrink
[ __ ] cryptocurrencies enormous carbon
footprint i'm particularly alarmed that
previously you know idled shut down coal
plants like the one operated by um
greenwich uh generation in seneca falls
new york are now being brought back
online to aid in cryptocurrency mining
uh you know and i don't know if the
chairwoman knows this but like in
montana a coal fire generating uh
station is now providing 100
of its energy to marathon digital
holdings for bitcoin mining under the
power purchase agreement
prior to the crackdown in china you know
it was estimated that nearly two-thirds
of all bitcoin mining took place in
china included in regions uh with very
heavy power generation sets in matagola
and and other uh areas but miss dixon
you know should the world's central
banks and governments be taking a more
active role in monitoring and regulating
cryptocurrency in order to bring energy
consumption and carbon emissions in line
with our own targets here in our country
at the paris agreement well you know
what would that look like
i think it's really important for us as
an industry to really focus on this
issue even without regulation i think
it's something that you need to always
balance about the value of what you
receive in terms of the harm that's
actually created to the environment so
we constantly have to be doing that kind
of analysis
i think that we all need to focus on
minimizing the energy consumption as
much as possible and then think about
how we can work with governments to be
able to consider the best way to achieve
that kind of the carbon neutral status
that i think a lot of folks want us to
get to so i encourage constant
discussion i encourage us to be
innovative this is one of the wonderful
things about blockchain and just
innovation generally you look and you
use technology to help to solve problems
just like this
yeah and you know the proof-of-work
model fundamentally isn't incompatible
with the environmental neutral like
future and so you know what tools uh i
mean you're saying we got to move in
this direction mistakes i mean what
tools
can policymakers like ourselves look at
to incentivizing you know to move us
towards that towards away from that
model how can policymakers accelerate
that transition away from carbon
intensive mining you know we know our
planet is burning uh the climate crisis
is here and i just want to get the
cryptocurrency community uh to become
part of the solution or not make this
crisis even worse so can you talk about
things that you would suggest for us to
be working on in regards to this issue i
think it's really important we've
actually engaged a third party to be
able to look at the additional energy
consumption not just for what i as i
mentioned the university of london did
with respect to the the work that they
did but i do think it's important to be
able and we're engaging in a third party
to look at all of the the different
transactions and how the network
actually can even be better and better
with this with respect to stuller i
think that same kind of work can be done
with all of the different types of
consensus mechanisms out there so i
think research and more focus on what we
can do to achieve sustainability and our
sustainability goals is important
mechanism and i think it would be really
good to continue that conversation with
you
thank you and i yield
thank you very much
the gentleman from tennessee mr rose
is now recognized for five minutes
thank you chairwoman waters and thanks
to ranking member mchenry for holding
this hearing and thanks to our witnesses
for hanging in with us uh for such a
long period of time uh your your
testimony and participation today is is
uh very important to helping us
understand this area and and craft the
appropriate policies going forward mr
beckman-free uh ftx and ftx us have
grown substantially over the past
several years could you tell us about
the economic impact from your
perspective that ftx us has in this
country
yeah thank you for the question
congressman um in addition to obviously
the impact in terms of the hiring that
we're doing um uh
and the support of a number of
initiatives in the country related to
uh job training uh and education um you
know we're also hoping that we can help
uh provide financial services to people
who have not had easy access to those
before if you think about the number of
intermediaries that are involved in a
traditional financial transaction
whether it's using a bank or whether
it's investing your assets
um that's a lot of points that can be
very difficult to navigate
for a number of people both in this
country and in the world
um you know we aim to be able to provide
services to to everyone here um all easy
to access on a mobile phone giving
inclusive and equitable access to
financial markets that have been missing
to a number of people
so obviously uh you describe a great
many benefits to the u.s economy so in
your view how do we keep this innovation
happening in the united states
so i think i'm optimistic that um you
know on the regulatory side um
we're not that far from that point and i
think that there are a few
clarifications that could go a very long
way here i think that on the market side
um you know having a framework with a
single regulatory structure and it might
have multiple regulators involved in it
the cftc and scc are both likely to be
involved to some extent but having a
single unified framework for futures and
spot digital asset uh disassets could go
a long way towards providing the sort of
experience that you can offer in a lot
of jurisdictions today
i think that giving clarity on the
stable coin side of you know audit
requirements for the reserves um but
without sort of squashing innovation by
requiring only a very limited number of
institutions
you